before we get to the video I want to
tell you about mushroom tomato goat
cheese kavat tapi I once thought that
none of those words should actually go
together but then today's sponsor
changed my mind factor it's a meal
delivery service and their meals come
straight to your front door which makes
the effort to cook immediately
convenient even better the food's ready
to eat and is packaged with flavor which
is why I'm now obsessing over the
mushroom tomato goat cheese kavat tapi
find your next meal Obsession by going
to factor75.com and get 50% off of your
first Factor Box by using te EV ss50 at
checkout or I could make it just as easy
as Factor makes meal planning and just
give you the link in the description
Factor offers tasty flavor packed
options on the menu each week to fit a
variety of Lifestyles like keto vegan
and more plus you can skip a week if
you're traveling or increase your meals
if you have a lot of TV to watch like me
if you're too busy to cook but want to
make sure you're still eating well this
fall just choose from one of Factor's 35
Plus meal options go to factor75.com for
50% off using the code
tvs50
[Music]
19 seconds into the previously awning
you show previously on what was previous
to the previously on if not the
previously awning see it's confusing
telling me that this is course on in the
previously on instead of putting it in
giant letters on my screen for me to
read you know so I can send you for
reading this report reads like a child's
fairy tale Jedi false Jedi Star Maps
star whales distant galaxies honestly
are we to believe any of it I mention
this is exactly what people who didn't
watch Rebel said upon starting Ahsoka
it's me I'm people also all those listed
things are real and witnessed by more
people than just Hera except false Jedi
I agree that's some madeup
Morgan eleth was leading a coordinated
effort by the Imperial Remnant objection
you can't object you're the judge you've
got to bang something to maintain order
what about the conflict on Mandalore I
understand understood that reference ah
yes I love having to watch seven
different things to stay up to date on a
Show's lore really makes it all worth it
creepier but why are you here I assume
it's because they ran out of cartoon
characters to Cameo apparently if this
series Falls below three cameos per
episode the bus will explode I am here
on behalf of Senator Leia Orana whoa see
3bo and a Leia name drop this is really
still not enough to salvage this scene
from Droid in order for me sorry I
object in the strongest terms it's weird
no one else is talking on the council
probably to save Disney money but it
gives the effect that no one really
gives a about this besides the guy
we're supposed to hate the court cannot
admit evidence of this kind from a mere
Droid mere Droid mere Droid sir you were
in the presence of one Anthony fing
Daniels and if he dragged his
77-year-old ass down to your stupid
little hearing you will treat him with
more respect here's three sins for your
outbursts pray I do not alter the sins
any further blink blink blink blink
blink
hey they made 20 more of these
recordings well that's a convenient way
to Cameo Hayden Christenson whenever
people get bored and the show needs to
pick me up show once again teases me
with seven lightsabers in storage that
we have no information about are they
from slain Jedi inquisitors a BOGO deal
from Bed Bath and Beyond are they
scented to match each season I need
answers Ahsoka well you should have said
something I did but you never
with your Droid for fun and not in a
fanfiction way it's an imperial
Minefield deployed around the arrival
Point how much time pass between the
witches telling thraw Ahsoka was coming
in now because I'm having trouble
believing it be enough time to set up
such an elaborate trap and now the ship
will dive into a ring of spacecraft so
dense it's impossible to see through and
because nothing is explained we're
forced to assume that a combination of
luck the force a well-built ship and
maybe a force field Shield thing are the
only reason they survived this Grand
Admiral as you anticipated the Minefield
was triggered by a pot of arriving
stormwells he predicted that
the witches did all the predicting damn
even in a galaxy far far away women
still can't get credit for their own
work what a shame the master was General
Anakin
Skywalker you can actually see and hear
the oh sh in his voice I'm so glad they
brought Lars melson back to play throm
because he's perfect in the roll go
ahead and take a sent off while I'm in a
good mood but don't expect that good
mood to last because I just finished
eating my Taco Bell and things go
downhill pretty fast after that being
this confident that your four massive
ink benss aren't going to ruin your
white suit this is why pocket protectors
exist people Pursuit we shall lose them
in the debris field stop saying debris
field I do not like this how did they
anticipate our arrival Ahsoka already
told you they took Sabine surely robot
as smart as yourself could predict
they'd take precautions in case sabine's
Master pursued them huh not all the
places I expected Star Wars to pull
inspiration from the Oregon Trail wasn't
one of them hope Ezra doesn't get
dissenter and die or do I damn it Star
Wars no more little green babies my
heart can only take so much Emperor die
don't worry he'll probably return turn
somehow how did you what find me you
never said it's complicated it's really
not that complicated you betrayed your
master and undid Ezra Sacrifice by
siding with his greatest enemy there see
not complicated yeah so where is Ahsoka
she
coming that's complicated just say your
Jedi Master was killed and you absconded
with her murderer it's not that
complicated great mothers I'm in need of
your assistance you going to give them
credit for their help this time or you
going to steal that too why are you
chanting you don't have a flying laser
pointer you're not one part of this so
stop trying to be in there click
something happened what was it don't
know feeling you don't know you
literally just said ahsoka's name Tano
being Ren whom we have wisely sent far
from here if you already knew you
weren't her Target then what was the
purpose of flushing her out of hiding
she was always going to presu sine
instead of attacking you so what did you
gain by tracking her in the debris with
the witches other than adding a few more
minutes in this episode's run time you
won't help your ambition drives you in
One
Direction my path lies in another as far
as excuses for abandoning someone goes I
think I prefer going out for cigarettes
using these lame ass ships instead of
the Tie fighters we can see you have
them I want to hear
[Music]
my sounds how dare you deprive me it's
my favorite noise in Star Wars aside
from the guitar bombs the fets
[Music]
use cute little alien reacts toing up in
a star St Wars property cliche I can't
leave him I'm going to circle up trying
to prove your space Western by stealing
from actual westerns this entire
sequence just screams gunm smoker Raw
Hide And if you're confused by those
references ask your grandpa as soon as
he wakes up from his nap to eat dinner
at 400 p.m. wopa Ezra is not immediately
shot in the head after leaving the
safety of his minimal cover to wopa wopa
in this scene hang on a few seconds ago
Thon said not to prepare defenses for
ahokas and she was just after Sabine so
why are these ships still chasing her
man to be an enemy pilot in the Star
Wars Universe just you and the Open Sky
and all of the Starships you can miss on
my mark turn these stairs into a ramp
for no reason thanks well now this is a
surprise that she landed in the one spot
where you were out of all the possible
Landing sites I agree that is a surprise
and a sinw worthy one at that the length
of her sweater Poncho in relation to her
lightsabers makes me wonder how often
Jedi have to explain their singed
clothing to the tailor Che lightsaber
take it you keep it fing what she
traveled to an entirely different galaxy
to return that to you and you just no
thanks this makes about as much sense as
Luke throwing away his old lightsaber
the ray brought him take youring laser
sword and cut people up that's what we
came here to see no the force is my Ally
that's all I need I'm going to call
on that and if I see you using
anything but the force in this fight I'm
going to order 66 sins just for you
every fight with saine is now just a
waiting game to see how long before she
loses both her blasters and has to pull
out the lightsaber it's not looking good
for you I don't know no dude I'd argue
it taking the two of you to make one
passable Jedi and hold her off isn't all
that great of a look
either okay now do that to Sabine it'll
be easy what are you waiting for
cooldowns or something can't defeat mea
Wikipedia summary tells me she survived
fighting Vader dude I think she could
take you if she didn't have a scorched
hand or runtime constraints you mean to
tell me that stupid ship has had Rockets
this entire time well I guess when you
have the worst fighter pilots in the
Galaxy on your tail why waste the
ammunition
kind of seems like you should have used
that weapon before now do they not have
a choosing the right weapon 101 class at
Jedi Academy destroy them wait wait wait
and then they do despite being given
orders by Shin they obey Ezra and hear
him out long enough for the rescue to be
perfectly
timed
deok oh look it's Mr the forces my Ally
what happened did you run out of force
do you wish you had a lightsaber right
about now I told you what would happen
if I saw you using another weapon Ezra
you brought this on
[Music]
yourself there San goes again hoarding
rocket darts M the pizza rolls are
almost done guys getting a feeling hey
so am I all warm and fuzzy it feels
weird but kind of nice this is exactly
how I'd want to feel in a series with
wait how many episodes are left one they
wasted how many episodes to get here I
think I might be going after all no
don't say that that's like the old
police Sergeant who says he's just one
day away from retirement I have a
feeling fans will Riot if Ezra dies ah
who am I kidding they'll Riot no matter
what no one hates Star Wars more than a
Star Wars
fan your ships smell like ass the City
of Townsville is under attack as a first
point of order I'd like to ask that the
opposing council's motion to compel
production of the defendant's client be
rejected as it's not relevant to the
litigation who's this the court
cannot admit evidence of this kind from
a mere Droid don't you call me a
Mindless philosopher you overweight glob
of Grease get along little buggies get
out of my way sounds me like someone's
trapped inside life's most complicated
shape a love
triangle he you do you want some myce
cream so bad we don't have any
run away run away